[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit Jana
pareigis willkommen an diesem Samstag
Wintersport und mehr gibt's von Sven
Foss schönen guten Abend schauen wir auf
unsere
Themen macht ein AFD Verbotsverfahren
Sinn Schleswig Holsteins CDU
Ministerpräsident Günther spricht sich
dafür aus parteichf März warnt hingegen
davor Stimmen für die Souveränität
Taiwan wählt einen neuen Präsidenten der
die Inselrepublik vor chinesischer
Einflussnahme schützen
will und Medaillenregen bei der EM die
deutschen rotlerinen holen innsbru
gleich dreimal
Edelmetall die Stimmen werden lauter die
für einen Verbotsantrag gegen die AFD
sind jetzt hat sich mit Daniel Günther
auch ein CDU Ministerpräsident dafür
ausgesprochen
die Diskussion über ein Verbot hat an
Fahrt aufgenommen seit ein Treffen
öffentlich geworden ist von Neonazis
unter anderem mit
afdptikern die bundesweite AFD wird vom
Verfassungsschutz als
rechtsextremistischer Verdachtsfall
eingestuft ein Bericht von Bern
Bentin Neujahrsempfang der AFD Duisburg
heute Nachmittag über 1000 Menschen
demonstrieren vor der Halle fordern ein
Verbot der AFD in der Halle ist jeder
der über 1000 Plätze besetzt die sieht
sich im Aufwind trotz oder gerade wegen
der
Verbotsdiskussion wir haben jetzt hier
heute einen sehr sehr großen neusempfang
deutlich größer als im letzten Jahr also
man sieht im Gegenteil eher dass es
vielleicht auch deutlich auch
positivepekte haben kann befeuert wird
die Verbotsdiskussion von den
Enthüllungen der vergangenen Woche
offenbar berieten afdptiker unter
anderem ein Vertrauter von Alis Weidel
mit rechtsextrem über die millionfache
Vertreibung von Migranten
angesichtsdessen spricht sich auch
Daniel Günther CDU ministerpräsid ent
aus Schleswig-Holstein für ein AFD
Verbotsverfahren aus es ist eine
rechtsextreme Partei ich weiß schon dass
das sehr sorgsam vorbereitet sein muss
deswegen dürfen wir da auch keine
Schnellschüsse machen aber eine große
Sympathie habe ich auf jeden Fall dafür
viele in der Union sind gegen ein
Verbotsverfahren und auch in den
Regierungsparteien herrscht Skepsis
einige aber wollen die Diskussion jetzt
in ihre Fraktion tragen dieses Netzwerk
diese AFD arbeitet genau daran unser
Deutschland abzuschaffen und wenn wir
das hinnehmen wenn wir zuschauen müssen
wir uns die Frage gefallen lassen ob wir
es haben laufen lassen sozusagen
Selbstmord aus Angst vor dem Tode auch
der Bundespräsident meldet sich heute
per Zeitungsinterview und warnt ein
Verfahren würde vermutlich sehr lange
dauern ich rate dazu dass wir uns auf
das konzentrieren was unmittelbar in
diesem Jahr möglich und notwendig ist
ein
Verbotsverfahren könnte sicher
eingeleitet werden aber und auch wohl
mit Erfolg aber ein solches Verfahren
würde nicht vor Mitte Ende nächsten
Jahres abgeschlossen sein die Diskussion
um ein AFD Verbot gibt es schon länger
seit dieser Woche aber in einer neuen
Intensität zu einem möglichen
Verbotsverfahren gegen die AFD äußert
sich der CDU Parteichef skeptisch ich
glaube wir müssen die Partei politisch
bekämpfen so Friedrich märz die
Auseinandersetzung mit der AFD im
Wahljahr beherrschte auch die
Klausurtagung des CDU Bundesvorstand in
Heidelberg mehr von Ines
Trams eine CDU Vorstandsklausur auf der
ein Thema dominierte das sogar nicht auf
der Tagesordnung stand der Umgang mit
der AFD sich abzugrenzen von der
rechtsaußenpartei reiche nicht mehr
künftig will parteichf März sie
inhaltlich angreifen stärker an die
Wähler appellieren schaut bitte genau
hin wen ihr da möglicherweise wählt das
ist keine Partei die dieses Land
wirtschaftlich voranbringt das ist keine
Partei die die Arbeitnehmer in
Deutschland besser ausstattet das ist
eine Partei die nur auf der Basis des
Populismus eine Zusammenarbeit mit der
AFD für März weiterhin ausgeschlossen
zudem will er verhindern dass CDU
Mitglieder gleichzeitig der
Nationalkonservativen werteunion
angehören können mit klaren Worten will
man die Ampel kritisieren aber ohne der
AFD in die Hände zu spielen wir müssen
schon deutlich machen wo die
Unterschiede sind und wir müssen
deutlich machen dass diese
ampelregierung für Deutschland keine
gute Politik macht und diese
Gradwanderung zu machen in dem in ein
vernünftigen Art des Umgangs in der
respektvollen Sprache das ist unsere
Aufgabe als bürgerliche Opposition in
ein TV-Duell wird der Thüringer
cduvorsitzende nun mit dem
rechtsextremen afdmann Björn höcke gehen
der mit Vorsprung die Umfragen in
Thüringen anführt für mich ist wichtig
die angebliche Alternative und börn
höcke eben auch in der Sache zu stellen
nur so werden wir Vertrauen bei den
Menschen zurückgewinnen die Ampel in
Berlin wirkt als Brandbeschleuniger für
den Protest und für die Sorgen der
Menschen das kommt im Osten noch mal
viel härter an weil die Menschen weniger
im portm haben alle müssten sich im
Wahlkampf engagieren so Parteichef März
der Kampf gegen die AFD sei eine Aufgabe
für die gesamte
Bundespartei mattes Feldhoff verändert
sich da gerade grundlegend der Umgang
der Union mit der
AFD ja es hat sich was verändert weil
die CDU feststellen muss dass der
bisherige Kurs nicht funktioniert die
Zahlen der AFD steigen seit Wochen und
Monaten an die Zahlen umfragezahlen der
CDU stagnieren bei 30 % ungefähr den
Kampf inhaltlich aufnehmen das hat man
heute bei ganz vielen gehört die Lage
schweißt die CDU tatsächlich zusammen
Auslöser war sicher die Konferenz in
Potzdam von der ja eben schon die Rede
war bei der führende afdptiker mit
rechtsextrem über die millionenfacher
Vertreibung von Migranten aus
Deutschland diskutiert haben
geschichtsvergessen gefährlich
deportationsfantasien haben das heute
CDU Bundesvorstandsmitglieder genannt
Friedrich Merz hat jetzt nicht nur die
Mitglieder seiner Partei aufgefordert
diesen Kampf inhtlich aufzunehmen
sondern hat diesen Appell ausdrücklich
auch an andere Parteien gewandt das sei
nicht nur eine Sache der CDU vielen Dank
für diese Einschätzung Matis
feldoff Bundesfinanzminister Lindner
bleibt dabei die schrittweise Kürzung
der Subvention für Agrardiesel will er
beibehalten dafür sollen die
Landwirtinnen und Landwirte bei der
Bürokratie entlastet werden das sagte
der reinischen Post auch Kanzler Scholz
kündigte an weiter mit den Bau nach
Lösungen zu suchen betonte aber dass
Subventionen nicht auf ewig bestehen
bleiben könnten auch heute haben viele
mit ihren Traktoren protestiert am
Montag wollen sie mit einer
großdonstration in Berlin ihre
Protestwoche
beenden taiwan hat über einen neuen
Präsidenten abgestimmt und das Ergebnis
dürfte die Machthaber in China alles
andere als freuen denn der als
abhängigkeitsbefürworter geltende lei
hat die Wahl mit rund 40% gewonnen sein
Konkurrent der chinafreundliche HU kam
auf
33%. China betrachtet Taiwan als
abtrünige Provinz und will es mit dem
Festland vereinigen notfalls mit
militärischer Gewalt Miriam Steimer
berichtet grünes Licht für Taiwans neuen
[Musik]
Präsidenten William Li ist gewählt
ich bin sehr glücklich William le wird
dafür sorgen dass die ganze Welt uns
sieht Taiwan wird Strahlen großartig nur
ein Wort großartig seine Rede eine
Botschaft an seine wählerinn und Wähler
aber auch an
China mit dieser Wahl von der ganzen
Welt beobachtet haben wir allen bewiesen
dass wir zwischen Demokratie und
Diktatur auf der Seite der Demokratie
sind
[Musik]
genau das ist das Problem für den
mächtigen Nachbarn demokratische Wahlen
wie hier im Tempel die es in der Logik
von chinas Führung gar nicht geben
dürfte da die Taiwan ja als Teil ihres
Staatsgebiets
betrachtet da es keine Briefwahl gibt
ist Softwareingenieur Juan jörhan extra
aus San Francisco hergekommen um seine
Stimme
abzugeben teuer manche sagen dass meine
eine Stimme nicht wirklich zählt der
Gewinner wird gewinnen der Verlierer
verlieren aber ich will meinen Teil dazu
beitragen und besuche gleichzeitig meine
Familie beim Stimmen auszählen kann
jeder zugucken zum achten Mal haben die
Taiwaner heute ihren Präsidenten gewählt
stolz feiern sie ihr demokratisches
Recht in taip Miriam Steimer Miriam was
bedeutet der Sieg des neuen Präsidenten
für das Verhältnis zwischen Taiwan und
China William le Sieg ist ein Problem
für Peking war er doch der Kandidat der
im Wahlkampf die größte Distanz zu China
suchte Peking bezeichnet ihn als
gefährlichen Separatisten und jetzt hat
er gewonnen und seine Partei damit schon
zum dritten Mal inf Folge in Chinas
staatlich kontrollierten Medien wird
nicht über diese Wahl berichtet auch in
den sozialen Netzwerken werden Inhalte
zensiert denn wenn man nach der Logik
der von Chinas Staatsführung geht dann
dürfte es diese Wahlen in Taiwan ja gar
nicht geben denn China betrachtet Taiwan
ja als Teil seines Staatsgebiets das hat
auch das Büro für Taiwan Angelegenheiten
heute abend noch mal bekräftigt da hieß
es Taiwan sei Chinas Taiwan und auch
diese Wahl ändere nichts an der
unvermeidbaren Wiedervereinigung wie es
in der Propaganda immer heißt Peking
könnte reagieren mit verschärften
militärmanövern mit dem Versuch Taiwan
diplomatisch zu isolieren und mit
weiteren wirtschaftlichen Sanktionen das
Verhältnis wird sich durch das
Wahlergebnis heute weiter verschärfen
Steimer vielen
[Musik]
Dank fast zwei Jahre ist es jetzt her
dass Russland seinen brutalen
Angriffskrieg gegen die Ukraine
gestartet hat und Präsident Putin sorgt
mit massiven Luftschlägen weiter für Tod
und Zerstörung rund 40 Raketen und
Drohnen feuerte Russland auf die Ukraine
ab dabei wurden weniger Geschosse als
sonst von der Flugabwehr abgefangen
teilte die ukrainische Luftwaffe mit
auch in der Hauptstadt Kiev mussten die
Menschen wieder die Nacht in Bunkern
oder in der Metro
verbringen zum Gazakrieg und den
Auswirkungen in der Region und da haben
die USA erneut einen Militärschlag gegen
die huthi Miliz im Jemen durchgeführt
ziel sei eine Radaranlage gewesen
hintergrund sind die Angriffe der von
Iran unterstützten huthi Miliz im Roten
Meer die huis betrachten sich als
Verbündete der Hamas und greifen
Frachtschiffe an bei den Sie eine
Verbindung zu Israel vermuten Benjamin
Daniel diese vorher nachher Fotos zeigen
die Zerstörung eines Flughafens im
jemenitischen hodeida nach der ersten
Bombardierung danach feuerten die hui
nach US-Angaben wieder mindestens eine
antischiffsrakete ab in der Nacht dann
erneut ein US-Angriff diesmal auf eine
huti
Radarstation die Angriffe sind mit
internationalem Recht vereinbar und vom
Recht der USA auf Selbstverteidigung
gedeckt wie es in Artikel 51 der
un-karte heißt und sie wurden erst
durchgeführt nachdem alle
nichtmitärischen Maßnahmen gescheitert
waren das sehen vor allem huti Anhänger
im Jemen ganz anders in der Hauptstadt
Sanaa wo die Radarstation lag
Verurteilten heute viele die Angriffe
Hass gegen Amerika und
Israel das ist ein internationales
Verbrechen die Belagerung der Krieg
gegen den Jemen warum tun sie
das diese brutalen Angriffe machen uns
nur noch stärker und standhafter sie
sollten Israelis bombardieren nicht uns
Muslime wir werden an der Seite Gazas
stehen bis zum Ende unseres
Lebens die US-Regierung unterstreicht
einmal mehr dass sie mit den Angriffen
keine weitere Konfrontation mit Iran
provozieren wolle er habe auch eine
entsprechende te Nachricht an den Iran
geschickt sagte Joe Biden vor wenigen
Stunden und für uns in Jemens Hauptstadt
Sanaa die von der hui Miliz kontrolliert
wird ist goline atai golini beeindrucken
die HU Miliz die Luftangriffe auf ihre
Stellung nein das sehe ich nicht die
Machthaber hier haben uns heute zum
ersten mal erlaubt unter Aufsicht zu
arbeiten und nach den Begegnungen die
ich hier hatte kann ich sagen die
Luftangriffe haben diese Bewegung eher
gestärkt eher revitalisiert kann man
sagen die USA gelten seit jeher als ihr
ideologischer Feind und dieser Feind hat
eine neue mobilisierungswelle verursacht
hat der huti Bewegung eine neue
rekrutierungswelle beschert vergessen
wir nicht diese politisch militärisch
religiöse Bewegung hat fast ein
Jahrzehnt schlimmster
saudischemiratischer Luftangriffe
überlebt und wenn sich heute als Sieger
des jemenitischen Bürgerkrieges was will
denn die HU mililiz eigentlich genau
erreichen mit ihren Attacken auf Schiffe
im Roten
Meer nun sie haben schon einiges
erreicht sie haben ein
Alleinstellungsmerkmal erreicht sie
sagen seht her keine arabische Regierung
kämpft so gegen USA und gegen Israel wie
wir das hat ihn ein enormes standing ein
enormes Prestige in der ganzen Region
beschert Saudi Arabien der ehemalige
Feind der fürchtet sich jetzt vor
Vergeltungsschlägen möglichen
Vergeltungsschlägen der huis und könnte
in den laufenden Friedensverhandlungen
auch bereit sein zu neuen Kompromissen
zu neuen Konzessionen vor allem aber
könnte durch einen möglichen neuen Krieg
die autoritär absolute Herrschaft dieser
Bewegung noch gestärkt werden und ein
neuer Krieg könnte natürlich auch
ablenken innenpolitisch von einer der
schlimmsten humanitären Krisen der Welt
aus dem Jemen golini anai danke
schön morgen ist es 100 Tage her die
radikalislamische Hamas in Israel rund
240 Geiseln nahm und 1200 Menschen
ermordete mehr als 100 Geiseln befinden
sich noch immer in Gefangenschaft in Tel
Aviv errichtete eine Vereinigung von
geiselfamilien den Nachbau eines
hamasunnels um das Bewusstsein für die
verschleppten wach zu halten auf dem
sogenannten Platz der Geiseln versammeln
sich zur Stunde tausende sie fordern
stärkere Bemühungen für die Freilassung
der geilseln
und vor Ort ist für uns l weport lü was
wissen denn die Angehörigen über das
Schicksal der
Verschleppten leider wenig bis nichts
das ist Teil des Leids dieser
Angehörigen der Familien und natürlich
auch der Geisen selbst in Gasa es sind
jetzt 100 Tage und das Rote Kreuz hat
nach wie vor keinen Zugang zu diesen
Geiseln das ist ein Teil des Problems
wir wissen dass unter den mehr als 100
Geiseln in der Hand der hamasterroristen
sehr alte Leute kranke Leute sind auch
kleine Kinder es sind Leute mit
Krebserkrankung mit chronischen
Krankheiten wie Diabetes oder Asthma sie
brauchen dringend Medikamente dass es
zumindest ein kleiner Lichtblick es gab
in den vergangenen Tagen Verhandlungen
über Qatar das Zugang zu Medikamenten
gewährt werden soll das heißt die
Geiseln sollen mit den lebensnotwendigen
Medikamenten versorgt werden mehr weiß
man aber nicht wirklich Regierungschef
netanau hat vor einer halben Stunde noch
mal in einer Pressekonferenz betont man
werde alle Geiseln zurück kolen das ist
aber leichter gesagt als getan denn
militärisch das ist kann man jetzt nach
drei Monaten Krieg sagen ist das eine
sehr schwere Sache die Geiseln werden
irgendwo in einem 100 km langen
Tunnelsystem versteckt es gibt also nur
die Verhandlungslösung und verhandelt
wird derzeit über eine geiselfreilassung
nicht vielen Dank Glück
wepot Donald Trump muss der Zeitung New
York Times rund 400.000 USDollar
Anwaltskosten erstatten über ein
entsprechendes Gerichtsurteil berichten
mehrere Medien die New York Times hatte
enthüllt dass Trump sein Vermögen nicht
aus eigener Kraft erarbeitete sondern im
großen Maße vom Unternehmen seines
Vaters profitierte dagegen hatte Trump
geklagt und verloren er muss nun die
anwaldshonorare und Gerichtskosten
tragen nach den Problemen mit der Boeing
737 max9 hat die US Luftfahrtbehörde das
Flugverbot für diesen Typ auf
unbestimmte Zeit verlängert 171
Flugzeuge müssen am Boden bleiben 40
werden erneut überprüft vergangene Woche
war bei einer Boeing diesen Typs kurz
nach dem Start ein Teil der Kabinenwand
herausgebrochen die Maschine musste
notlanden die amerikanische
Raumfahrtbehörde NASA hat ihr neues
Überschallflugzeug x59 vorgestellt das
Flugzeug ist das Herzstück eines neuen
nasaprjektes das Besondere am neuen Jet
ist die Maschine soll ohne
Überschallknall fliegen können im
Verlauf des Jahres sind erste Flugtests
über ausgewählten Regionen der USA
geplant bei denen weitere Daten
gesammelt werden
sollen das Hochwasser der letzten Wochen
in Deutschland hat vielen Menschen
schwer zu schaffen gemacht dann kam die
Kälte für die Stabilität der
strapazierten Deiche war das gut für
viele aber die ein Haus besitzen ist die
Kombination aus Hochwasser und Frost
derzeit eher ein sich zuten mollau
berichtet als das Wasser endlich sank
kam der Frost diese Kleingartensiedlung
be Hannover hat es hart getroffen viel
ist kaputt gegangen bei all den
Wassermassen der Leine nun kämpfen Sie
hier auch noch gegen den Frost wie hoch
der Schaden sein wird ist noch nicht
klar Dimitri dimitrius geht davon aus
dass er viel sieren
muss wenn das gebäe intakt ist und keine
allzuoßen Schäden bekommen hat könnte es
roundab 3 bis 6000 € sein in Ferden an
der Aller die Straßen sind durch die
Fluten abgesagt das Mauerwerk
durchdungen von Wasser in den Kellern
der Häuser laufen noch die Pumpen wie
bei Ralf eldang er hat nicht nur Sorge
vor der nächsten Stromrechnung sondern
auch vor der Kälte Frost höchstens W ich
mal sagen wir durch das FE feuchte
Mauerwerk ne dass man da Angst hat W ich
mal sagen dass das jetzt am Gebäude
jetzt friert aber deswegen haben wir ja
auch die Sandsäcke noch liegen lassen
die Kombination Hochwasser und Frost
kann Folgen haben für
Hausbesitzer wenn Gebäudeteile die
feuchtet sind
äh und der Frost kann eindringen dann
dehnt sich das Wasser um 10 % aus und
das hat eine erhebliche springkraft die
Frostperiode hat auch geholfen vieler
Orts wie hier im Landkreis Zelle
durchgefrorene Deiche bedeuten mehr
Stabilität
die ist einerseits gut die Verwallung
werden dadurch gut abgestützt dass die
Oberfläche ist schön fest und hart doch
andererseits es wird wieder toun Keller
könnten dann vollaufen weil das
gefrorene Wasser ins Grundwasser fließt
die Pegel werden dann steigen also keine
Entwarnung und im Sport heute viel
Wintersport und Bundesliga sen ja und
wir starten mit dem Rodel weleltcup
Innsbruck gleichzeitig die
Europameisterschaft der Rennrodler die
olympiasäge von 2014 wendel alt gewann
heute im Doppelsitzer hinter Österreich
und Lettland Bronze für die deutschen
Frauen gab es sogar insgesamt drei
Medaillen Jessica Degenhart und che
Rosental haben sich schon mit Platz 2
abgefunden da unterläuft den klar
führenden ÖsterreicherInnen Egle und Kip
ein grober Schnitzer Absturz auf Platz 9
Weltcupsieg also für Degenhard Rosental
zugleich emtitel und gute Perspektiven
in der neuen olympischen Disziplin im
Einsitzer wimpernschlagentscheidung
gegen Jul taubitz und für die
Österreicherin madelen Egle
24us Sekunden Rückstand für taubitz
Dritte mit Anna breiter eine weitere
deutsche taubitz bleibt aber vorn im
Weltcup und auch auf der Natureisbahn
von St moruritz sind deutsche Athleten
erfolgreich den Zweierbob Weltcup gewann
Johannes Lochner vor seinem Dauerrivalen
Francesco
Friedrich groß die Freude bei Johannes
Lochner erneut hat er zusammen mit Georg
Fleischhauer das sichtlich frustrierte
Team Francesco Friedrich Frank 2
verwiesen Lochner am Start im zweiten
Lauf zwar etwas langsamer in der Bahn
aber schneller als Friedrich insgesamt
beträgt sein Vorsprung 25 Hund Sekunden
auf Rang 3 der Schweizer Michael Vogt
einen deutschen Doppelsieg feierten auch
die Frauen im monobob Lisa buckwitz
gewinnt vor Laura Note und der
Australierin Brianna Walker und beim
Superteam Event hat Schispringer Andreas
Wellinger im polnischen Wisler einen
neuen Schanzenrekord aufgestellt
144h Meter schaffte Wellinger zusammen
mit Stefan lei belegte er damit Platz 3
hinter den Duos aus Slowenien und
Österreich das Format bei dem zwei statt
vier Athleten ein Team bilden ist bei
den Springern
umstritten der 17 spieltag in der
Fußballbundesliga stand im Zeichen der
Trauer um Fußballlegende Franz
Beckenbauer in allen Stadien wurde das
am Sonntag Verstorbenen Weltmeisters in
einer Schweigeminute gedacht die Teams
spielten mit Trauerflor
und hier die Ergebnisse vom Nachmittag
Tabellenführer Leverkusen schießt in der
94 minute den Siegtreffer in Augsburg
Frankfurt gewinnt in Leipzig mit 1:0
dann drei Unentschieden Freiburg Union 0
köln-heidenheim 1:1 Mainz Wolfsburg
ebenfalls 1:1 der FC Bayern gewann schon
gestern gegen Hoffenheim mit 3:0 alles
zum Abendspiel Darmstadt Dortmund ab 23
Uhr im aktuellen sportstudioum und
morgen noch Bochum gegen Bremen und
Gladbach gegen Stuttgart zur Tabelle
Leverkusen beendet die Hinrunde als
Herbstmeister im Januar die Bayern haben
am 24 nordes Nachholspiel gegen Union
Berlin Wolfsburg führt die zweite
Tabellenhälfte an Mainz Köln und
Darmstadt bleiben auf den
Abstiegsplätzen und später im Aktuellen
Sportstudio darf ich dann
Nationalspieler Jonathan t vom
Herbstmeister Bayer Leverkusen begrüßen
sehr schön danke es W gerne beim Wetter
geht es gleich um viele Wolken Regen und
Schnee von östtin terli an diesem Abend
können Sie das heute journal um
22:45 Uhr sehen mit Anne gellineck auf
[Musik]
Wiedersehen schön guten Abend und
herzlich willkommen zum Wetter in den
nächsten Tagen bekommen wir mehr und
mehr Schneeschauer aus dem Norden sehen
hier über der Nordsee ist es noch hier
in blau also der Regen der allmälich
dann Schnee übergeht und dann nach
Deutschland reinzieht aber was man noch
erkennt ist vom Rekord warmen
Nordatlantik kommt viel Feuchtigkeit aus
dem Westen her und hier haben wir es mit
Regen und Schnee in der Südhälfte zu tun
wir schauen erst in die kommende Nacht
und da gibt es Regen und Schnee vor
allem den höheren Lagen auch Hochnebel
ist dabei im Norden ja und Glätte ist
natürlich dann inklusive im Süden bildet
sich Nebel oder es klart auf bei
tiefsten Temperaturen dort dort bis -10°
eisig kalt 4° im Nordwesten Richtung
Nordsee generell in der Nordhälfte
plusgade morgen dann weiterin vor allem
der Nordhälfte dicht bewölkt erneut
viele Wolken Hochnebel Regen und Schnee
ist dabei ganz im Süden teilt
Sonnenschein vor allem in den Bergen und
vor allem dann wenn sich der Nebel
auflöst Temperaturen dazu maximal -1 bis
+ 5° Richtung Nordsee die nächsten Tage
ja es gibt Regen und Schnee am Dienstag
he nur noch Schneefälle und am Mittwoch
wird es richtig ungemütlich im Süden
einen schönen
Abend